après quelques changements de santé
enfin après quelques années j'étais
acceptée puis j'ai pu faire un don ça
fait du bien je me suis dit pourquoi pas
j'ai du temps libre et j'ai du temps
c'est une bonne journée à la clinique de
sang de la place des jardins aujourd'hui
il y a plus de donneurs que de place
disponibles mais c'est loin d'être
toujours le cas je dirais que la
situation au Québec elle est
préoccupe à dire que il faut sans cesse
rappeler aux gens qu'on a des collègues
les banques de sang sont indispensables
et celles des mains Québec est plus
basse qu'elle ne le devrait en ce moment
surtout pour le sang au positif le plus
commun des groupes sanguins et pour le
sang ou négatif je suis au négatif alors
donc c'est un sang qui est recherché et
en fait si je peux aider la communauté
ça me fait plaisir de le faire Emma
Quebec a besoin d'au moins 1000 dons par
jour pour maintenir sa réserve de sang
en ce moment on recueille seulement de
800 à 900 dons par jour et on estime
qu'il faudrait 2000 nouveaux donneurs
par mois pour maintenir la banque un
seuil acceptable 2000 dollars c'est peu
considérant toute la population éligible
à faire un don
les amis ces gens éligibles à peine 3%
donne alors il y a de la place pour des
nouveaux donneurs
selon Emma Québec si la réserve actuelle
de sang ou négatif diminuant encore les
hôpitaux devront annuler 20% des
chirurgies non urgentes et peut-être
plus
le problème c'est le renouvellement de
la banque de donneur régulier il manque
de 109 et particulièrement celui des
jeunes plus difficiles à rejoindre
depuis la pandémie quand on voit dans
l'Universités et cégep je remarque que
des filles sont beaucoup plus présentes
et ils sont beaucoup plus ils viennent
plus souvent que les garçons nous on a
essayé de motiver nos amis mais du coup
enfin ils ont pas voulu donc on est venu
toutes les trois je voulais en faire un
déjà dans ma vie puis je me suis dit que
là c'était l'occasion j'ai vu l'affiche
et je me dis pour les gens qui en ont
besoin c'est toujours bien Emma Québec
c'est un annuellement plus de 1000
collectes de sang ou qu'elle participe
200 000 donneurs ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal